After 40
Do you notice that
your eyes get tired very easily?
Blood sugar and blood pressure also start acting up.
There are two great foods on the table
Tomatoes and corn
This is the food we eat every day.
That's right
Don't be fooled by their seemingly ordinary appearance.
Do you know
which food pairs best with tomatoes
to stabilize blood sugar?
There is another type of corn
that is best for protecting the eyes.
You often eat
Your retina will thank you!
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Eat tomatoes with this
Stabilize blood sugar and prevent aging
After 35 years old
Do you feel that your skin
isn't as bright as it used to be?
pores have also become larger.
When laughing
Fine lines appear
Come
Eat a set of anti-aging and blood sugar stabilizing partners
It's really great!
Tomatoes and onions
Lycopene in tomatoes
can eliminate free radicals in your body.
Delaying cell aging
Quercetin in onions
And sulfides
It can reduce inflammation
It can stabilize blood sugar
Tomatoes and onions together
More than just making your skin younger
Cardiovascular health
Better metabolism
Beautiful wife
What kinds of dishes can be made with tomatoes and onions?
I can cook
Stir-fried pork slices with tomatoes and onions
That's good.
Another one is
Scrambled eggs with tomatoes
Then add onions.
It's delicious
Um
Very delicious
Mothers
Make one tomorrow
Tomato and onion dishes
Your skin
will be very beautiful.
younger blood vessels
Tomatoes protect the heart and fight six types of cancer
Three types of people should not eat
Guess!
Which vegetable makes a doctor's expression change?
Apple?
No
ah
I tell you
It's a tomato.
Because Italians say that
when tomatoes turn red
the doctor's face turns green.
This bright red tomato
Eating this
can protect your heart
and whiten your skin.
Even cancer fears it
Lycopene in tomatoes is the king of antioxidants.
What are the benefits of lycopene?
Women can eat it
Anti-aging
Whitening
Men can eat it
Protect your prostate
and strengthen your heart
Lycopene can also help
cleanse blood vessels!
Research indicates
Lycopene is said to be able to remove deposits in blood vessels.
Lower bad cholesterol
It is LDL
LDL cholesterol
Preventing heart disease
Tomatoes are so nutritious that even cancer fears them.
Studies have found
that people who regularly eat tomatoes
may reduce their risk of six types of cancer.
Wow, that's amazing!
What are the six kinds?
Prostate cancer
Stomach cancer
Colorectal cancer
Ovarian cancer
Cervical cancer
Breast cancer
That's awesome!
Yes
But I need to remind you
Some people are not suitable
Who should not eat tomatoes?
Three types of people
The first type of kidney patient
Kidney patients or people undergoing dialysis
Why eat less?
Tomatoes are high in potassium.
People with kidney problems should not eat too much.
The second type of person with poor digestion
Don't eat too much.
Because the malic acid and citric acid in tomatoes
may cause excessive stomach acid
Excessive stomach acid
Causes gastroesophageal reflux
The third type
People taking beta blockers
for high blood pressure
I suggest you consult a doctor first, it's safer that way.
Three ways to eat
Lycopene doubles
Tomato and tofu have anti-inflammatory properties
Beautiful wife
What are you eating?
Tomato dipped in that
Ginger juice
soy sauce
It's delicious!
Try it.
I think it looks like Huang Renxun.
He also uses this to eat, doesn't he?
yes
This is a dish that people in the south really like to eat.
He said he really misses Taiwan's ginger tomatoes.
It's delicious!
I'd like to try it too.
Yeah, you should try it.
It must be delicious
Tomatoes can protect blood vessels
Ginger’s gingerols and shogaols.
It is natural.
Anti-inflammatory ingredients
Effectively reduces inflammation in the body
Do you know whether tomatoes
are better eaten raw or cooked?
I think it's better to eat it cooked.
Tomatoes can be eaten raw or cooked.
Both are very good
You eat raw tomatoes
You will get plenty of Vitamin C.
It has the effect of whitening and boosting immunity.
After the tomatoes are cooked...
Like making scrambled eggs with tomatoes
You can eat lycopene
Helps the small intestine absorb
Moreover, it protects the cardiovascular system.
Anti-inflammatory and anti-aging
There are three ways to eat it.
Double the absorption rate of lycopene
First, eat it with oil
Second, eat it heated up.
Third, choose the redder tomatoes to eat.
Let's talk about eating more first.
Lycopene is fat-soluble.
It is oil-soluble
It will dissolve in oil.
So mothers are making scrambled eggs with tomatoes
When adding a little olive oil
This can greatly improve
the absorption rate of lycopene.
The second is to heat it up before eating.
After you cook the tomatoes
It will release more lycopene.
Lycopene is more effectively absorbed.
Research shows
Put the tomatoes at 88ºC
Heat for two minutes
Absorption rate 6%
If heated for 15 minutes
Absorption rate 17%
Heat for half an hour
It can actually reach 35%
Wow, that's amazing!
The last third
When you buy tomatoes
Choose redder tomatoes
The redder the tomato
The higher the lycopene content, the better.
You can cook tomato meat sauce
when cooking pasta.
Another option is to make tomato and tofu soup.
Both of them are delicious.
yes
Tomatoes meet tofu
The combination of lycopene and soy isoflavones
It can exert antioxidant effects
Moreover, it regulates hormones.
And combats chronic inflammation
Please pay attention
Tomatoes and tofu eaten together
Don't eat it often.
Eating too much is not good
Why
It may cause the problem of kidney stones.
Eating a type of corn is good for your eyes
Preventing retinal degeneration
Next, we will introduce
Corn that helps protect your eyes
Is corn considered a vegetable?
No, it's not.
Corn is a starchy food belonging to the whole grain category.
There are three common types of corn.
sweet corn
sweet fruit corn
glutinous corn
Sweet corn
People whose eyes are often sore
Here, eat more sweet corn.
Lutein and zeaxanthin in sweet corn
High content
There is plenty
β-carotene
Help protect your eyes
Slowing down retinal degeneration
The second type is sweet fruit corn
sweet fruit corn
It's actually a variant
of sweet corn.
It comes in white and yellow.
There are also yellow and white ones.
It is sweeter
The texture is like eating fruit.
It can be eaten raw or in a cold salad.
Do you know what kind of corn is used for roasted corn?
I know
The third type
What is the third one?
roasted corn
This is glutinous corn.
That's right
Glutinous corn has white varieties.
Some are blackish-purple
This is the kind you bought at the night market.
Some people boil it in water.
glutinous corn
It's chewy and bouncy when you bite into it.
right
It is also rich in dietary fiber.
It can promote gastrointestinal motility.
Don’t throw away this part of the corn
it can be used as tea to reduce swelling and lower blood pressure.
Corn is not just
Corn kernels are delicious
In traditional Chinese medicine, it is also considered a medicine.
Corn silk, corn roots, and corn leaves are all valuable.
Let's start with corn kernels.
It is rich in unsaturated fatty acids
Lecithin and Vitamin E
It can protect blood vessels and lower cholesterol.
You are someone with high blood lipids.
You can eat some corn
with your regular three meals.
It's pretty good.
The second is corn silk.
Don't treat this treasure as trash.
Throw it away
What a pity
In ancient times
people dried fresh corn silk, ground it into powder
and added a little wine to eat it.
Did you know?
It can treat breast redness and swelling in women.
blocked milk ducts
Or symptoms such as feeling cold and having a headache.
The effect is very fast.
Modern people also study
Corn silk tea has the following benefits:
Lower blood pressure and stabilize blood sugar
Diuretic and swelling-reducing
Diabetic patients
People with high blood pressure
You can go to convenience stores and supermarkets.
Buy corn silk tea
Drink it as a beverage
It's pretty good.
Thirdly, corn roots and leaves can also be used in medicine.
It is recorded in the Compendium of Materia Medica
When describing urine as having a sandy
dribbling sensation
Or what we now
call gallstones.
It will be unbearably painful
You can boil the corn roots and leaves
into a soup.
Frequent drinking
A great friend for reducing water retention and losing weight
Baby corn has three times fewer calories
than regular corn.
Girls who want to maintain a slim figure
have something to tell you
Baby corn is your best friend for weight loss.
Baby corn per 100 grams
It has only 31 calories.
Baby corn has only one-third the calories
of whole corn.
It's crunchy when you eat it.
The mouth feels satisfied
Very low in calories
My feet have been feeling a little swollen lately.
You can eat baby corn.
Baby corn has a relatively high potassium content.
In every 100 grams of baby corn
Contains 222 mg of potassium
It has the effect of diuresis and reducing edema.
Your feet are slightly swollen.
then you can eat this food
Baby corn
Who should not eat baby corn?
There is a type of person who should eat less.
People with urinary incontinence
Otherwise,
become a frequent visitor to the toilet at night.
Beautiful wife
Do you know the difference
between baby corn and whole corn?
I know.
Baby corn is a type of corn.
small
Small corn is just right.
It means baby corn.
Baby corn, or kids
Baby corn is also good for pregnant women.
Baby corn is rich in folic acid.
It can meet the folic acid needs of pregnant women.
Eating the right amount can reduce the risk of birth defects.
Help prevent nerve defects
Okay
good
Dear fans
We have launched the membership channel.
If you agree with my promotion of Traditional Chinese Medicine
The concept of taking care of one's own health
Small monthly donations are welcome.
It only costs the price of two cups of coffee!
Or become our VIP sponsor
With you by my side
Only then can we go further.
Thank you so much